We will discuss the results of
the classification tree model.
So we first observe that
the overall accuracy
of the method regarding the
percentage that it accurately
predicts is 80%, compared
to 75% of the baseline.
But notice that this is
done in an interesting way.
For bucket one patients, the
two models are equivalent.
But of course this
suggests the idea
that healthy people
stay healthy,
which is the idea of
the baseline model.
The cost repeats is
valid in the data.
But then for
buckets two to five,
notice that the accuracy
increases substantially from
31% to 60%-- it doubles--
from 21% to 53%--
more than doubles-- and
from 19% to 39%-- doubles.
There's an improvement from 23%
to 30%, not as big as before,
but there is indeed an
improvement for bucket five.
But notice the improvement on
the penalty from 0.56 to 0.52
overall.
A small improvement
in bucket one,
but a significant improvement
as we increase on the buckets.
For example, here
for bucket five,
the penalty error decreases
from 1.88 to 1.01,
a substantial improvement.
So we observed that there's
a substantial improvement
over the baseline, especially
as we go down on buckets.
It doubles the accuracy over
the baseline in some cases.
And so we have seen
there's a smaller accuracy
improvement in bucket five, but
there's a much lower penalty
in the prediction
for bucket five.
So what is the edge
of the analytics
provided to D2Hawkeye?
First and foremost, there
was a substantial improvement
in the company's
ability to identify
patients who need
more attention.
Another advantage was
related to the fact
that the model was in fact
interpretable by physicians.
So the physicians were
able to improve the model
by identifying new variables
and refining existing variables.
That really led to
further improvements.
Finally, and quite
importantly, the analytics
gave the company an edge
over the competition using--
that the competition used
last century methods.
And the use of machine
learning methods--
in this case,
classification trees--
provided an edge that
also helped Hawkeye
when it was sold to
Verisk Analytics in 2009.